let's go in our peach frontage exits
gregg al Bakir and it's John over here
so we're gonna have we're gonna cover
five movie news stories of the week
today we look through all the news of
the week and there's like five I really
stuck to us that we feel like talking
about big the big stories man green
screen background here bad green screen
effects a little bit here is the shadow
many more lifes working on it and the
thing because of you guys were anything
ever to get it there ventually they look
so promote going to LR sounds going to
get better just a bad back the mic is on
alright imagine that it's already great
before we hop into this movie news a
week I wanted to give a big thank you to
everyone on patreon I noticed in the
past couple days we've got a few more
pledges some are pretty big pledges
thank you guys yeah really for also
notice there's about three of you who
increase your pledges and even after
that so a lot of you increased it by a
lot and that is very touching and you
best believe you're going to be getting
your rewards for sure Rosa para we have
a special surprise for you just for you
can't tell you what it is it has a
variety but we got a special it would be
cool yeah I don't like you're going to
like the way you look I guarantee it
and also we'll be announcing the next
Google hangout will be will do a couple
more this month we want to make sure
everyone who pledged least thirty
dollars or more because that's the
rewards here for that that you will be
included in it so I got a message
everyone and find out everyone's
schedules yeah
keep a lookout anyway let's start
hopping into this news of the week lewd
adam wingard cast a direct godzilla vs.
King Kong oh boy Adam winger he's done
films such as the guest the Blair Witch
yes alright Blair Witch for just Blair
Witch or Blair Witch I figure out what
it is and your neck your neck he did the
VHS movies or parts of the VHS movies
one of the big forces behind those and I
think he did a at least one more he's
he's really tearing up the indie horror
scene and now he's he's getting the big
bump oh yeah she's
I'm honestly a little surprised it's
only happening now it's a little wait a
little your winder to assign him for I
think not when you think about the fact
that they gave Godzilla to the guy made
trick-or-treating
now that's a Michael Dougherty lets
Godzilla - oh yeah is Godzilla versus
King Kong yeah I mean maybe they want to
make it actually scary now maybe that's
the thing they're going for that's the
only death guess I could come up with
yeah why they would want him and then
why they got the guy who could
trick-or-treat did you Godzilla - um you
know cuz King Kong the the reboot that
we just recently had this part of its
what's this one college 20 different
universe another Universal Yaga the
universal monsters called the dark
universe this is the monster universe
and I I I'm not thinking that Adam
winger was being tapped to do this
because he's never done a big budget I
mean we got something just a little
questionable about it to me when you get
when you're when you're doing your major
crossover moving and you take your
chance with an indie horror director and
what whose last film wasn't really
received all that well I'm a little bit
surprised that they specifically penned
him for this but his other films have
been received true certificate yeah as
always hare nag like oh yeah I'm Dee
darling and and I'm like I don't know I
don't ever feel great when they tap
directors from the indie market and give
them something giant but they do this
all the time with directors who have
less films under their belt that are
less a guy named so like I don't know I
feel like you can do it so it's a little
bit like I don't know what this is going
to look like whereas with Michael Dory
and Godzilla - it's like he's done a
Superman movie so I know at least that
he's got experience handling a big
production and lots of effects Superman
would be yeah he did Superman Returns he
directed it remember to record Superman
return directed cyber know he wrote it
to me I'm sorry that I did Bryan Singer
directed Superman Returns
trivia I'm sleeping man but yeah he at
least worked on that movie and I'm sure
he was around he and Bryan Singer's seem
close so it's like him he at least had
some big you know pedigree as a writer
on it yeah yeah definitely
oh but yeah without a Wingard I'm like
you you haven't done something that's
big I don't think he can't but also he
is a guy who you know his films have
edges you see is weird because I feel
like if you heard Adam winger was doing
King Kong like when before King Kong was
on I would have been more on board for
that thank God and I feel like the
director who did King Kong should be
doing godzilla vs machine gun actually
did it if after watching king kong and
like it's a Rock'em Sock'em monster fest
that's what I would want Godzilla vs.
King Kong to be and I would want a King
Kong to kind of be a little scarier and
have more tension and all that stuff
yeah so this is I think he can probably
pull it off a working on something like
this is pretty uh that's pretty major
than honestly if it was me if I was just
thinking about what I know about these
guys already and partly as I like to see
what people do outside of the ranges
that I'm familiar with but I almost feel
like Michael Dougherty would be the best
choice for King Kong because King Kong
has the most potential remaining that's
because of the waist Skull Island it has
creatures and stuff I would have given
Adam Wingard Godzilla too and I want a
big event
Jordan vote Katie Kagura suggestion yeah
but as it stands I'm interested I'm have
to wait and see because whenever it's
always a gamble like you never know when
it's going to work out and it's gone to
the point that it works out enough where
I'm not doubtful anymore like my initial
reaction is not doubt anymore you know I
kind of Jenkins just did Wonder Woman
yes oh what the hell would have thought
that and she's not way crap she did an
amazing job of that film and she's not
directed tons of features yeah and she's
not directed a huge big-budget movie
either yeah as long as they care about
giving us a good entertaining flick and
that's all Godzilla
that's all Godzilla vs. King Kong needs
to be as an entertaining Rock and saw
that way doesn't my tonight paper yeah
yeah it doesn't need to be it honestly
doesn't need to be as good as the first
Godzilla need to be and it doesn't need
to be as impactful of the rebooted King
yeah exactly and you know what like I do
think there's something cool about Adam
when you're doing this because to me
he's got enough films under his belt
enough experience that I think maybe
them tapping a guy like him is cool
because he might actually be able to put
his stamp on it more so than a director
who's only done one indie now that's
been acclaimed one and I'm hoping that
he will infuse horror in it you know so
yeah what kind of I kind of wanted a
little bit prevalent in in the Kong
Skull Island movie yeah the one I wanted
to feel a little scary yeah instead of a
you know awesome monster fest because a
lot of people were satisfied with that
bloody war as sad as I was out which is
fine it's a way to go but I would have
liked to have seen more horror sofas
yeah and I thought they had
opportunities like with that whole Toby
Kebbell story like wandering around a
lot like and so I think if you're going
to get Adam winger to do this you know I
would want him to still infuse the
elements he knows how to work best which
is order and if you're getting two of
the greatest monsters in cinematic
history to battle it out which is like
that here that is why I'm just expecting
an action flick yes that's why they
think the choice to get him to direct
surprised me because I was expecting
maybe an action director to do it yeah
so if you're going to get a guy who's
known for her and the guest has action
elements in it oh yeah
first I have an IV that's the one of his
I got seeing you that ass home you know
yeah and I've heard it is gut horror
stuff in it but it is also pretty bad
people sell it to me badass first yeah I
had like just you need to see it
could've awesome
the music - yeah like a good soundtrack
oh my god let's hope so let's hope so
let's move on to the next one hey hey
can you smell what The Rock is cooking
oh goodness a pate wolf wolf sandwiches
Dwayne Johnson is being I to play the
wolf man and universals dark universe
I'm no longer surprised that Johnson's
ID for anything and I'm never surprised
when he signs on because he apparently
could tackle any project this might
schedule somebody somebody pointed this
out in like a facebook status update and
like in the short amount of time dwayne
johnson has had like an acting career
he's done something like 60 movies or
like a huge amount of move oh he did
yeah
I don't know how he does it I don't
either did he does he have a personal
life I feel like the rock is just always
at the no his daughters name like if
they have a kid like he does have a kid
and I'm like do you know your family and
all but you know your family do you have
any friends like what you say you're
always worried not I live in a gym and I
admire you like you can't you gotta give
though the work ethic nad-rid back you
got it
hey the rocket that dude hustles hard
and I any wars without enough yeah every
time I see you he's bigger I'm like how
do you know how are you possible man
every overweight person has the excuse
that I'm too busy the rocket has no
shoes alright I'm not too busy you're
not too busy for [ __ ] submit I have no
excuses it's amazing what this guy does
ah now he's apparently going to join the
dark universe yeah and um you know I'm
still very iffy about the dark universe
and then the mummy comes out this week
actually oh boy that really maybe we
should do or we should review the
Brendan Fraser once you see Arthur
should only do the thermal and work our
way backwards against them yeah exactly
so I guess I'll go three one two yeah
yeah you an order of fundin yeah um yeah
I think this is fine uh what would make
me okay with this like especially ok
with it because the rock is massive he's
built he's a broker a person is very
common like the Rockets already imposing
and I've been out being a werewolf so if
it was a werewolf I guess that would
make him that much more horrifying well
the reason why I be okay with it is if a
studio decides to do the most amazing
decision in the world
make him practical then it would be you
yeah yeah cause I'm here to finally do
it right happen for me if he could do
practical effects on the eyes of the
rock is it out of his busy schedule
willing to commit the time and synonym
make him fear for that long yeah the
amount of money I'm sure he will make up
yeah die then he's got time yeah I do
unless it's one of those like crap
stories of you know like he's not
playing the wolf man but he's distorted
the wolf nanny
he has to say as much as people don't
like the Benicio del Toro what I do like
that movie and uh you know despite its
flaws and that's the thing I was happy
to kind of happen was he got into the
makeup for a lid didn't he I thought oh
my god the transformation was CGI but
the wolf man I believe was a breakfast
oh yeah I Rick Baker was really upset
because he wanted to be with like
technology is advanced we can do a crazy
transformation sequence yeah exceed you
that was an American Werewolf in London
come out 70s all right I want to say
that was in 80's probably a really
eighties uh yeah everything able to do
it then okay no doubt good things so
like I feel like that is you know as
much as it's easy to be like little
practical I do believe that that is a
real opportunity yeah it's like sin
effect if you could have done that for
real and you've got Rick Baker like
basically itching to do it I don't get
why you didn't and I guess the only this
grandma this is still just a rumor we
are aware of that is yeah my not even
happening you know but the fact that you
know he's most likely being hide to do
this just kind of obsessed me a little
more in its own way because on my why is
the start of universe an
action-adventure series yeah we're going
to create twenty jobs that you know it's
going to be an action-adventure it's
like The Mummy is promoted as
action-adventure horror flick this I'm
like yeah some of the same thing
action-adventure horror flick and I'm
like why why why the action adventure
park yeah
horror adventure I guess yeah I guess
the things at the end because the mummy
the Brendan Fraser ones are kind of
for adventures yeah and and I get every
action in there but but there's also
there Indiana Jones yeah exactly exactly
there's still a period piece that's
still there's still a very distinct
style and flair and the action has
suspense in it because you know the
villain is is scarier yeah a human with
a gun oh yeah those jump scares yeah the
first couple I'd like the Beatles and
then then like the mummy is a key
looking and and you know I I want to I
agree with you it's like I want to be
open to what they're doing but I feel
like they're taking I get their point
about we kind of created the cinematic
universe each of the monster movies sort
of picked up where the last one left off
and yeah and they're all kind of in the
same the Universal Monsters is a
recognizable blah blah blah I get it but
I do feel like every time I hear an
announcement or see a trailer I feel
like they're taking something special
and making it more generic to compete
with everything else because everything
is an action-adventure now and what
makes these special is that they are
over my movies now they're 150 million
dollar action-adventure flicks yeah
and I not that not that horror on that
level doesn't work
I liked World War Z and that's you know
kind of a Geo adventure of its own but
again this is this franchise is going to
be a see it to believe it sing almost on
a case-by-case basis for me yeah because
they're gung-ho with this before they've
even had one of these be a well-received
hick yeah I know I look I like doing
John I do like he makes me happy I'll
watch a third of doing John feeling I
will because I don't wanna watch
Baywatch I do do a no money and no one
like no I don't want to watch I don't
think the rock is charming and funny no
matter what he's in he always brings the
game now yeah so on the one hand I want
to be optimistic about this but on the
other hand I'm like why did you ask him
to play The Wolfman and what about what
and I get again it makes sense with how
they seem to be proceeding Tom Cruise's
the star of the mummy the rock will be
the star of Wayne Johnson will be the
star of The Wolfman but oh
no there's the way this would work for
me is if it gave him a chance to
demonstrate some more range because as
much as I like the rock he's always the
rock yeah or the most part he's always
charming and buff and toughened never
leave his better he's best if the role
is kind of funny at least yeah even
though faster Pierce is not a comedy
he's funny
oh yeah he's always equipment yeah yeah
exactly and uh um I can't see it and I
doubt that they're going to try and
surprise me is the thing because I see
the trailer for the mummy and I'm like
yeah this does look like mummy and
possibly yeah nothing I haven't seen you
do at a bunch of other movie I just look
a little more serious this time
yeah and so you know especially having
seen the Wolfman and having seen a
couple of those seagulls and having seen
the more recent one I don't think it
should necessarily be a carbon copy of
those no but I just don't think it's
going to go into a place that I'm gonna
be relevant yeah alright guys well you
can head over to our patreon to catch
the full movie news of the week segment
but for you guys on YouTube we made sure
to give us give you guys leave the two
biggest new stories of the week you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
catch this guy - on Humphry on twitter
and instagram is a social media manager
of Rittenhouse comm and click that
notification Bell to be notified every
time one of our videos eating out much
love to all you people on YouTube
everyone who watches our videos
seriously much lovely every single one
of you guys are some of the greatest
supporter we've ever had in our entire
lives thank you very much